wie sehr lenkt sie eigentlich gerade die
Diskussion um Waffenlieferungen an die
Ukraine ab von ihrer eigentlichen Arbeit
und Wirtschaft und Klima
das ist meine eigentliche Arbeit unter
anderem weil ja das
Wirtschaftsministerium auch eins der
Häuser ist das für die Exportkontrolle
zuständig ist das heißt die positiven
aber auch die negativen Entscheidungen
welche Waffen die Ukraine oder anderen
Länder bekommen geht auch über meinen
Schreibtisch insofern ist das jetzt
keine Ablenkung sondern ich halte das
für eine höchst relevante und höchst
wichtige Diskussionen in Deutschland die
wir ja insgesamt auch ganz gut gestanden
haben das stimmt und trotzdem ist die
Frage und da merke ich auch dass ich
viele Leute sorgen die Forderung nach
immer mehr neuen größeren stärkeren
Waffensysteme wenn man sie mal zurück
geändert wir haben sehr viele rote
Linien hin gemalt Leopard war so eine
rote Linie haben wir mittlerweile
gerissen die Ukraine will jetzt
Kampfjets und will U-Boote was antwortet
der deutsche Vizekanzler
das ist richtig ist schwere eine schwere
Entscheidung aber eine richtige
Entscheidung der Ukraine auch
Kampfpanzer zu geben wir erleben ja ein
fast
altmodischen Krieg und das sage ich
völlig ohne zynismus ist einfach ganz
bedrückend und fürchterlich mit
anzusehen oder zu berichten zu bekommen
was dort im Osten der Ukraine passiert
und da brauchen Sie um eine russische
Offensive abzuwehren Verstärkung am
Boden deswegen ist es richtig dass wir
der Ukraine diese Kampfpanzer liefern
die sollten da jetzt auch schnell
hinkommen wir haben lange vielleicht ein
bisschen zu lange gezögert diese
Entscheidung zu treffen
in der großen Geschlossenheit
wenn eine Entscheidung dann gefällt ist
hätte man sie möglicherweise auch vorher
Fällen können aber das ist natürlich
auch im luftleeren Raum gesprochen weil
es richtig war darauf zu dringend dass
diese Entscheidung gemeinsam mit den
Amerikanern gefällt wird das hat ja auch
dazu beigetragen dass die Amerikaner
sich ebenfalls daran beteiligen und das
war eben davor nicht möglich also
insofern ist das das rückblickende
hätten wir schneller sein können immer
wenig hilfreich nun allerdings sollten
wir nach vorne sehen die Ukraine Stellen
mit den Panzern ausstatten das ist aber
auch das was Sie brauchen und ich halte
von dieser Debatte die jetzt gerade über
U-Boote oder Flugzeuge geführt wird
wenig das ist nicht das was im Moment
ansteht ansteht ist die kampfmaterial zu
bringen trotzdem nochmal die Frage was
denken sie darüber also wenn man den
Chef der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
Christoph Häuschen hört der sagt ich
glaube dass die Lieferung von Kampfjet
sehr wohl adäquate ist und die koordina
besser zu schützen Saskia Essen hat die
Lieferung von Kampfjets nicht
ausgeschlossen vom Kanzler
zurückgepfiffen worden ihr Parteichef
und minor vergangene Woche hier hat die
Lieferung von Kampfjets an die Ukraine
ebenfalls nicht ausgeschlossen was sagen
sie
ich sage dass ich das nicht richtig
finde jetzt kommt jetzt zu liefern jetzt
nicht die ganze Zeit über
generell nicht ich wir haben die ganze
Zeit über eine eine eine
Balanceakt vornehmen müssen ich kann
mich an eine Sendung erinnern bei Ihnen
Herr Lanz vor einem Dreivierteljahr
ziemlich gefragt haben tun wir alles um
die Ukraine zu unterstützen und ich habe
damals gesagt nein wir tun nicht alles
wir tun das was wir für angemessenheiten
ohne selber Kriegspartei zu werden das
heißt wir hatten die ganze Zeit eine
doppelte Aufgabe maximale Unterstützung
der Ukraine ohne selbst Deutschland oder
Europa oder die Welt in diesen Krieg
hineinziehen zu lassen das ist natürlich
nicht ganz klar wo dort die Linie
verläuft und einige sagen und ich
respektiere auch diese Sorge dass schon
die Entscheidung Kampfpanzer zu liefern
zu weit geht ist ich finde das nicht
aber zwischen Kampfpanzern und Kampfjets
oder der Ausrüstung der Marine ist noch
mal ein Unterschied und aus meiner Sicht
sollten wir diesen Unterschied waren das
heißt dieses richtig jetzt die Ukraine
in ihrem Selbstverteidigungsrecht gegen
die russische Aggressionen das müssen
wir uns immer wieder klar machen was wir
hier eigentlich gerade erleben nämlich
ein fundamentalen Bruch von Völkerrecht
ein Angriff auf die europäische
Finanzordnung ein Angriff auf ein
souveränen Staat deswegen müssen wir die
Ukraine unterstützen ohne selbst
Kriegspartei zu werden und der Grund ist
der fundamentale Unterschied ist dass
nach dem was ich weiß die Ukraine für
die modernen westlichen Kampfjets die
Wartung des Westen braucht und sie
wahrscheinlich damit dann oder wir damit
den Schritt zu weit gehen könnten und
Kriegspartei zu werden deswegen sage ich
die Leopard Panzer das ist eine richtige
Entscheidung auch an den notwendigen
Entscheidung aber zwischen den
kriegs-panzern und Kampfjet ist ein
Unterschied
wenn du noch mal daran erinnern also ich
verstehe diesen Balanceakt über den sie
gerade sprechen ich ich verstehe dieses
mulmige Gefühl dass man hat wenn du
trotzdem noch mal daran erinnern genau
das waren die Argumente das können die
gar nicht bedienen da werden wir möglich
teilweise Kriegspartei um den Leon nicht
zu liefern das war die Argumente gegen
Marder gegen Gepard gegen andere
Luftabwehrsysteme Maß heimers alles was
wir dann am Ende tatsächlich und
trotzdem geliefert haben das heißt sie
schließen aus dass jemals die Situation
kommen könnte dass wir doch Kampfjets
liefern
naja wenn sie sagen jemals und
irgendwann Entferner Zukunft kein Mensch
weiß wie sich die Situation entwickeln
aber für das was wir im Moment
überschauen können würde ich sagen dass
es wäre jetzt die falsche Entscheidung
also macron ist das sagen darf nur
nur weil Argumente sich wiederholen
heißt es ja nicht dass sie an der einen
Stelle richtig sein können
möglicherweise waren sie davor falsch
aber an dieser Stelle können Sie ja
richtig sein und ich habe eben versucht
anzureißen zumindest ohne zu tief in die
waffengattungsfrage reinzugehen wo ein
ein Unterschied liegt zwischen
Kampfpanzern und den Kampfjets nämlich
in der möglicherweise das will ich ja
zugeben dass man nie genau weiß wann
dieser Schritt da ist und man
möglicherweise okay geht er darin ähm
selber dann zu dicht an den Krieg zurück
okay das ist interessant weil ich eben
waren sie im Widerspruch zu ihrem
Parteichef der das nicht ausgeschlossen
hat jetzt schließen Sie selber auch
nicht mehr aus und ich verstehe das und
man spürt auch diesen Balanceakt um
Dienstag
nur nein ich will nur sagen wenn man
sagt jemals überhaupt
in den nächsten Jahrzehnten das sind
natürlich Horizonte die sie aufmachen so
weit kann ja kein Mensch in die Zukunft
blicken aber für die Situation die wir
im Moment haben und die wird ja
andauernd verstanden meine ich gibt es
zwischen Kampfpanzern und Kampfjet
seinen Unterschied ich wollte nur nicht
wie soll ich sagen dann eine verbal Horn
und eine Diskussion reingeraten das ist
auch richtig so und das ist auch
unglaublich heikel wieder kommuniziert
wird wie fanden sie eigentlich die
Aussage der Außenministerin ihrer
Parteikollegin Annalena Bärbel bevor sie
antworten wir hören einmal kurz rein um
den ganzen Kontext mal zu verstehen
Finger pointing at each other doesn't
bring peace and freedom to your train
also demokratic politician in my country
where we have a government with
different active
things and we are taking action joint
together yes we have to do more to
defend you crane yes we have to do more
also Tanks what the most important and
the crucial part is that we do it
together and that we do not do the blame
game in Europe because we are fighting
against Russia and not against each
other thank you
wie fanden sie das Bekämpfen einen Krieg
gegen Russland
ja das war wenn man es wirklich liest
nicht präzise wir sind nicht in einem
Krieg ich habe es ja gerade ausgeführt
eine der roten Linien die die
Bundesregierung die ganze Zeit versucht
zu erkennen auszulocken und
auszubalancieren ist nicht Kriegspartei
zu werden das ist für Anna-Lena genauso
wichtig wie für mich insofern
finde ich die gewollte Mist
Interpretation dieses Satzes verrät auch
viel und das hat an der Lena Werbung
nicht gemeint und der Kontext ist für
mich völlig klar es geht in der ganzen
Rede darum die Gemeinsamkeit
herzustellen das ist die Arbeit der
Außenministerin von morgens bis abends
die ganze Zeit in einer Solidarität zu
bleiben und ein wie soll ich sagen etwas
verrutschten Satz zu skandalisieren
finde ich
nicht richtig ich finde das
ja ich finde dass der Kontext völlig
klar ist und Annalena nicht Russland den
Krieg erklärt hat oder was ich da alles
lesen muss
zu behaupten das ist der Punkt es geht
immer um die Frage wie dann sowas
interpretiert werden kann und über uns
reden wir jetzt in dem Fall nicht wir
schauen uns aber mal an wie sich die
russische Propaganda genau einen solchen
Satz nimmt und was dann daraus entsteht
Werburg Ministerin astrana del reicher
happy video
[Musik]
kriegen sie sowas mit wenn sowas im
russischen Staatsfernsehen läuft
ich glaube niemand der einer liberalen
und rationalen Weltordnung zugewandt das
kann gut finden was noch ein russischen
Staatsfernsehen läuft oder was russische
Medien hier in Deutschland machen ich
erinnere daran dass der die erste
Begründung für den Angriff noch einmal
den völkerrechtswidrigen Angriff der
jetzt viele viele zehntausende Tote nach
sich gezogen hat ist die Ukraine vom
Faschismus zu befreien die Ukraine die
regiert wird von einem jüdischen
Präsidenten also die russische
Propaganda verdreht systematisch Ursache
und Wirkung
Opfer und Täter das einzige was die
Wahrheit ist ist die Lüge die wir aus
Russland hören und Sie werden sich immer
ihr Opfer für die Propaganda suchen die
werden sich immer was rauspicken aus dem
Kontext reißen gegen die Intention
verdrehen wir können uns nicht dagegen
schützen dass Russland versucht und wir
können es dagegen schützen aber wir
können es nicht dagegen die werden es
immer wieder probieren irgendwas nehmen
und
für ihre Zwecke zu missbrauchen aber der
Missbrauch das ist doch das erkennbare
Muster der russischen Berichterstattung
einmal kurz in die Welt geblickt der
Kanzler Olaf Scholz auf Staatsbesuch in
Brasilien bei Lula Klang teilweise sehr
euphorisch und kommt zu dieser ganz
bemerkenswerten Pressekonferenz in dem
es in der zwei Dinge klar werden das
erste Brasilien wird nicht liefern wird
kein schweres Gerät keine Panzer auch
keine Munition liefern die gerade für
deutsche Waffen dringend gebraucht
würden und Lula geht sogar noch weiter
Stichwort Propaganda russische
Propaganda gibt der Ukraine quasi eine
Art mit Schuld an diesem Krieg und sagt
wir sollten mit China gemeinsam jetzt
dringend verhandeln das ist ein Sound
der so ganz anders klingt wie der der
Bundesregierung
das ist so und es ist bedauerlich dass
es nicht gelungen ist aus diesem Bündnis
aus dieser Allianz die sich gebildet hat
und die Ukraine zu stützen mehr zu
machen eine Reihe von Staaten die sich
offiziell dem nicht anschließen
unterstützen die Ukraine sehr wohl
direkt oder indirekt aber es ist schon
richtig wie sich es dargestellt haben es
gibt auch eine große Reserviertheit von
Ländern die wir gut in dieser Allianz
gebrauchen könnten es gibt eine
Geschichte dazu wenn ich die kurz
erzählen darf ich war Ende des letzten
Jahres in Südafrika hat das dort auch
thematisiert ähnliche Situation also wir
halten uns raus und europäischer Krieg
geht uns nichts an
ist eine russische Ukrainisch
Angelegenheit ich habe den den deutschen
den europäischen Standpunkt klar gemacht
und gesagt bei Unrecht kann man sich
nicht neutral verhalten und dann wissen
die Südafrikaner darauf hin dass als ihn
Unrecht geschehen ist also in der Zeit
der Apartheid der Unterdrückung des
Rassismus in Südafrika
der Westen wenn ich so reden darf lange
weggeguckt hat und gute Geschäfte mit
der apartheidtheitsregierung gemacht hat
aber es war dieser wird Union die die
Befreiungsbewegung unterstützt hat das
heißt es gibt da eine emotionale eine
geschichtliche Bindung die heute schwer
zu verstehen ist wenn man nur auf die
Gegenwart guckt die aber natürlich den
Blick geprägt hat ich will damit sagen
wir haben auch nicht immer alles richtig
gemacht das ist keine Entschuldigung
dafür dass man in einer Situation wo so
ein großes Unrecht passiert versucht
sich rauszuhalten was ist eine gewisse
Erklärung aus dem historischen Kontext
der jeweiligen Länder noch einmal das
ist nicht gut aber ich will damit ein
bisschen den Punkt setzen dass wir jetzt
nicht aus der moralischen
Überheblichkeit dass wir immer alles
richtig gemacht haben andere in ihrer
historischen Situation sofort
verurteilen müssen sondern wir müssen
beharrlich und ruhig und ein bisschen
hinter den Kulissen daran arbeiten dass
die Unterstützung der Ukraine weitergeht
und auch breiter wird er zeigt nur wie
schwer es ist da Allianzen zu schließen
und einmal noch ganz kurz deutsche
Innenpolitik und einfach weiß mich
interessiert sprechen mit einem
Kabinettsmitglied gibt große
Verwunderung darüber dass nennt sie
Phaser die Innenministerin nach
Medienberichten als SPD
Spitzenkandidatin in Hessen antreten
will um gleichzeitig Innenministerin zu
bleiben was halten Sie davon oder anders
gefragt würden sie so ein Wahlkampf
nebenher noch unterkriegen oder würden
Sie das zeitlich gar nicht schaffen
naja manchmal machen Bundesminister am
Ende der Legislaturperiode ja auch
Wahlkampf und sind auch im Amt aber im
Moment wäre es natürlich das Ende zu
viel
andererseits ist es ja erstmal ein
Medienbericht und vielleicht sollte man
erstmal abwarten wie sich die
Innenministerin und entscheidet und
selbst äußert bevor man in einer
aufgeregten Welt aufgrund von habe ich
gehört und könnte sein berichten
das finde ich auch immer
sie hat noch gar nicht noch gar nichts
gesagt aber alle haben schon mal eine
Meinung finde ich immer so so begrenzt
solide aber sie haben offenbar auch eine
sie finden es nicht so gut wenn sie es
machen würden das ist ja jetzt klar
geworden
ich meine Meinung ist wenn sie Fehler
soll ich erstmal erklären wie es da
weitergeht und der Rest ist dann im
Wahlkampf sie wird wissen wenn Sie
beides macht was genau das zum Thema
werden wird im Wahlkampf und umgekehrt
das ist ihre persönliche Entscheidung
oder die ihrer Partei die Sachen
auszutarieren also ich arbeite gut als
Kollege mit ihr zusammen was man so sagt
freue mich auf die nächste
Zusammenarbeit genau trotzdem nicht nur
was man so sagt ich finde ich finde ich
finde diese Debatte ist jetzt wirklich
48 Stunden zu früh ohne dem Motorrad war
moderationshinweise geben zu wollen nee
fragen Sie mich das nächste mal
frag sie gerne ich habe nur das Gefühl
irgendwann mal ist man so einem Land und
gerade in der jetzigen Situation in dem
auch gerade wieder eine riesige
Migrationsdebatte haben in der Landräte
Alarm geschlagen weil sie sagen wie
kriegen die Leute nicht mehr unter wir
hatten gerade Bock steht und andere
Dinge eine Innenministerin finde ich ist
es irgendwann an einem Land schuldig mal
deutlich zu sagen was sie demnächst zur
beruflich hat
ich denke das wird auch jetzt sehr
schnell tun ja also das schnell ist
nicht das erste Wort das mit dazu
einfällt egal lassen Sie uns über
Wirtschaft sprechen und die ökologische
Wände wie sehr überschattet der Ukraine
Krieg den jahreswirtschaft
Wirtschaftsbericht oder bisher hat
dieser Ukraine Krieg und wirtschaftlich
geschadet habe
also erst einmal überschattete ihn
zurecht denn das ist tatsächlich das
Moment die Epoche definierende Ereignis
und so sehr die Wirtschaft und auch der
Klimaschutz hoch auf der
Prioritätenliste stehen
ich hätte eher Sorge dass der Krieg in
Vergessenheit gerät dass die
Unterstützung sich abschleift dass man
nicht mehr hinguckt und vergisst auch
historisch vergisst was da eigentlich
passiert und was da wer da was gemacht
hat und auslöst also insofern darüber
bin ich mit dem Jahreswirtschaftsbericht
nicht ganz oben auf der Titelseite stehe
sondern erst die Berichte über die
Leopard Panzer oder über die
militärische oder die humanitäre
Situation in der Ukraine kommt dann ist
das mehr als gerechtfertigt und ja
natürlich das war ja klar dass
Sanktionen aber dann auch die wenn man
so will Konter Sanktion also die
Reduktion und nachher das Abstellen das
Gases aus Russland die deutsche
Wirtschaft schwer fordern wird ja
treffen wird wir sind dann erstaunlich
gut durchgekommen also ich erinnere
daran dass wir im letzten Sommer noch
Prognosen hatten von führenden
Wirtschaftsinstituten die sagten ohne
russisches Gas bricht die deutsche
Wirtschaft um 12% ein oder bist du 12%
ein das wäre dann doppelt so tief wie
bei Corona ich weiß nicht ob einige
diese die Graphen des Wachstums in
Deutschland so vor Augen haben die
bewegt sich so in kleinen hupeln immer
nach oben und dann kommt ein tiefers
tiefes FAU da rein das ist die
corona-pandemie der Lockdown der
politisch hergeführte Stillstand der
Wirtschaft das sind dann so -6% knapp
gewesen -12 passt im Grunde auf gar
keine Grafik mehr drauf das war die
Prognose und sie ist ausgeblieben wir
hatten im letzten Jahr ein Wachstum ein
Wachstum von jetzt
1,8%, also gut würde man sagen nur waren
die Bedingungen eben nicht gut wir haben
dieses Wachstum mit
hohen Preisen bezahlt die Unternehmen
hatten teilweise riesige Existenzängste
und es ist sehr ungleich verteilt weil
eben einige Unternehmen gerade die
Energie intensiven an diesem Wachstum
nur begrenzt teilten aber andere
Sektoren der verbraucht die
Dienstleistung auch der Maschinenbau
sich gut entwickelt haben
transformative Angebotspolitik das ist
der neue Begriff könnte man das auch
übersetzen mit ausufernder sie lachen
ausufern der Subventionspolitik also was
ist das was ist das was da gerade
passiert wir haben schon beim letzten
mal darüber gesprochen diesen Inflation
reduction Act der der Amerikaner
400 unfassbare Milliarden wobei
gestreckt auf zehn Jahre das relativiert
sich dann alles nichts desto weniger
führt dazu dass viele deutsche
Unternehmen sehr deutlich und lauter
darüber nachdenken ihre Standorte in den
USA entweder auszuweiten ihre Produktion
auszuweiten heißt deutsche Arbeitsplätze
gehen verloren wie groß ist ihre Sorge
von diesem meltdown sagt man glaube ich
auf neudeutsch von diesem Abschmelzen
der der deutschen Industrie die ja
immerhin 20% der deutschen Wertschöpfung
ist wie groß ist ihre Sorge dass dieses
Land ernsthaft Wohlstand verliert
wenn ich darf gehe ich mal zu diesem
etwas tatsächlich sperrigen Begriff aber
vielleicht ist er so schwer ich dass er
dann wieder
auffällt betrifft transformative
Angebotspolitik und Orten ist ein
bisschen ein genau
Angebotspolitik ist eigentlich das gegen
der Gegenteil von Nachfrage Politik und
wenn man das in dem wie soll ich sagen
in die politischen Kontext macht dann
machen die Konservativen und die
Liberalen die neoliberalen immer
Angebotspolitik das heißt die senken die
Steuern sie sorgen für die Regulierung
die fördern auch Bildung also sie
schaffen ein größeres Angebot aus dem
sich dann die Wirtschaft bedienen kann
und das schafft dann Nachfrage seitlich
einen Impuls das sozusagen traditionell
verbunden mit lauter Leuten die ich
nicht auf meine politischen Ahnen
beschreiben würde also Dragon und
Hatcher und so weiter das ist quasi
Angebotspolitik und ist er auf der
konservativen Liberalen Seite des
politischen Spektrums vor Ort während er
bei mir politisch zu Hause die
Nachfrageseite steht also man
unterstützt die Menschen die im
Kaufverhalten erhöht die Löhne erhöht
die Sozialtransfers sorgt dafür dass
Menschen sich was leisten können und
dann kaufen die auch Güter und das
kurbelt die Wirtschaft ab und jetzt
steht diese beiden Blöcke immer so ein
bisschen stark gegenüber und ich habe
überlegt was kann denn eine Ampel
Antwort sein und dabei herausgekommen
ist die transformative Angebotspolitik
die in der Tat sagt wir nehmen die
Elemente auch der will ich sagen zuvor
bekämpfen Seite wir gießen Sie aber
nicht blind mit der Gießkanne übers Land
also senken Steuern für alles und jedes
weil die Geldern müssen ja nachher
irgendwie wieder reingeholt werden wir
geben Sie zielgerichtet aus für die
Bereiche wo wir jetzt die Transformation
den Wettbewerb um die Transformation die
neue Industrien die neuen
Produktionsweisen die neuen digitalen
Prozesse wo wir die stehen müssen und
der Gedanke dahinter ist pragmatisches
Vorgehen keine fruchtlosen ideologischen
mehr über Heere Prinzipien sondern das
was hilft wird gemacht und es wird
zielgenau gemacht und nicht blind und
dusselig und deswegen finde ich es
eigentlich ein ganz schön Begriff weil
er den politischen Diskurs verwirrt
aufbricht im gewissen Sinne und etwas
aufzubrechen dass Leute noch mal
nachdenken dass sie das in Frage stellen
was sie davor gedacht haben dass sie
vielleicht eine gewisse Überraschung
erstmal verarbeiten müssen ist ja
meistens nicht so schlecht also das ist
dann transformative Angebotspolitik und
sie ist ein Bestandteil einer Antwort
die wir dringend geben müssen dass
dieses Land wettbewerbsfähig ist und
zwar nicht in erster Linie gegen
Frankreich Dänemark und Österreich mit
denen stehen wir im gewissen Sinn auch
in einem volkswirtschaftlichen
Wettbewerb aber die eigentlich
Auseinandersetzung findet wirtschaftlich
mit den USA und mit China vor allem
statt und Sorge ist vielleicht das
falsche Wort weil Sorge so lähmend
klingt dann startet man drauf wie das
Karnickel auf die Schlange und sagt oh
je das besorgt mich so sehr aber
angesprochen herausgeforder Stuttgart im
Ehrgeiz gepackt sollten wir alle sein
nur wenn wir mit der briesigkeit
weitermachen wie in den letzten Jahren
darf ich sagen Jahrzehnten und glauben
das wird schon alles gut und im
Zweifelsfall kriegen wir billigeres
russisches Gas da müssen wir uns nicht
anstrengen aber es ist halt billiges
russisches Gas dann verlieren wir das
was Europa in Deutschland ausgemacht hat
nämlich internationale
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit wir müssen uns
schon auf den Hosenboden setzen und hart
arbeiten so transformative
Angebotspolitik das sozusagen der der
theoretische Teil aber jetzt mal ganz
konkret den Leuten geht es um Jobs die
Leute brauchen einen auskommen die Leute
müssen mieten bezahlen die Leute stehen
vor der Frage wie und wovon bezahlen wir
eigentlich diese Energiepreise um die es
geht und es geht ganz ernsthaft um
deutsche Industrie Arbeitsplätze zum
Beispiel dieses schwedische
batteriestheater Nord wollte dass
die ganze Zeit eigentlich fest
entschlossen war in Schleswig-Holstein
zu investieren Batteriefabrik aufzubauen
die gehen jetzt in die USA und überlegen
was Schleswig-Holstein noch weil sie
ganz offensichtlich angezogen werden von
diesen
mega-subventionen aus den USA VW weitet
seine
Standorte in den USA aus und so weiter
biontech die deutsche Firma als es um
Corona ging lagert jetzt die
Krebsforschung zumindest nach England
aus also was müssen wir tun um all diese
zukunftsträchtigen Jobs und die Jobs die
es in der Zukunft wirklich braucht nicht
zu verlieren was ist ihre Antwort darauf
wenn ich einmal kurz das aufdröseln darf
weil das schon
unterschiedliche Herausforderungen sind
die Amerikaner haben ein großes
Subventionsprogramm aufgelegt das ist
dieser Inflation reduction Act über den
wir schon gesprochen haben zu dem man
lange reden kann der viel ist auch sehr
toll macht weil es endlich eine
Entscheidung für eine grüne Wirtschaft
ist die die Amerikaner getroffen haben
also da kann man gar nicht dran rumhauen
aber er hat auch problematische Teile
und die betreffen eben die beiden
angesprochenen
Produktionslinien Batterien und
Automobilindustrie sie schreiben vor
dass in den USA diese Förderung nur
Autos bekommen die in den USA fertig
montiert worden und das ist gegen die
internationalen Wettbewerbsregeln und
sorgt natürlich dafür obwohl es ein
Regelbruch ist das erstmal Investitionen
gerade im Batterie und Automobilbereich
in die USA fällt werden ich komme gleich
zur Antwort bei biontech ist es ein
anderer Grund das hat mit den USA und
dementsprechend erstmal gar nichts zu
tun sondern mit der
Regulierung und vor allem der
datenregulierung in Deutschland das
glaube ich ist noch von der
corona-pandemie halb im Ohr das sehr
viele Pharmaunternehmen die erhobenen
Daten nicht nutzen können und da findet
im Moment vor allem der
forschungsfortschritt statt dass
künstliche intelligenzprogramme aus den
datenclustern heraus Krankheitsbilder
filtern und dann die Produkte darauf
entwickeln dazu brauchst du aber die
Daten so dass deutsche Pharmaunternehmen
teilweise leichter mit Daten aus
südamerikanischen Staaten oder Städten
arbeiten als mit den Städten in den sie
gerade zu Hause sind und das hat den
irgendwie nicht mehr gepasst was man
nachvollziehen kann auch daran wird
gearbeitet in diesem Fall von Karl
Lauterbach was die Inflation redakt
Frage angeht wir werden morgen von der
Europäischen Kommission ein großes
antwort-paket hören ich würde sagen es
gibt drei Bestandteile die wir machen
müssen wir müssen vor allem schneller
genehmigen es ist nicht die alleine
Geldsumme die ist das haben sie eben
gesagt die ist hoch aber da hält Europa
mit
aber es ist die Geschwindigkeit der
Genehmigung und das geht wahrscheinlich
rüber in den zweiten Teil wenn über die
Bauwirtschaft und die Windmühlen geredet
wird
entscheiden nicht mehr politisch wir
entscheiden nur noch juristisch und über
den Verwaltungsweg und das geht so nicht
wir müssen nicht alles machen aber das
was wir machen müssen wir schnell machen
das ist das erste Geschwindigkeit in der
Genehmigung und in der auskehren von
förderbescheiden oder Baugenehmigung
oder was auch immer das zweite ist
Zielgenauigkeit das ist die
transformative Angebotspolitik wir
müssen uns schon entscheiden was die
zukünftigen Märkte sind und wenn ich
einen alten modisches Wort mal nehmen
darf diszipliniert dabei bleiben also
Disziplin den Plan auch umzusetzen und
nicht jedes Mal wie aufgescheuchte
Hühner rumzurennen wenn man irgendwas
mal irgendwo gehört oder gelesen hat und
die die Disziplin heißt den Wettbewerb
voll volley zu nehmen und der Wettbewerb
wird über die Grünen Leitmärkte erfolgen
und das der dritte Punkt ist in der Tat
das Bereitstellen von Geldern das muss
man nicht wenn man funktionierende
Märkte hat aber wenn alle anderen
Subventionen auskennen dann muss man
sich diesen Wettbewerb stellen und auch
diese Frage hat Europa eigentlich
beantwortet nun kann man sicherlich hier
und dann noch mal eine Schippe
draufpacken aber wir haben große
Programme geschnürt die jetzt für
Ausgaben werden müssen und aus diesen
drei Komponenten müssen wir jetzt
schnell eine starke Antwort machen sind
aber voll dabei das zu tun auf der Skala
von entstehen dir würde ich sagen
auch mit Blick auf den Blick auf den
Hauswald war im Grunde war das eine
feste Zusage dass ein Projekt kenne ich
habe heute noch mal mit dem CEO gesimst
wir sind ganz eng beieinander wir
telefonieren fast täglich mit der auf
der Arbeitsebene miteinander ich würde
sagen so im November waren wir kurz
davor zu sagen wir machen das jetzt die
haben sich entschieden dann kam der
Inflation redakt und das sah aus wie
jetzt gehen wir in die USA das war alles
umsonst jetzt würde ich sagen ist wieder
Unentschieden ich kann Ihnen das nicht
versprechen dass sie kommen aber die
sehen wie hart wir daran arbeiten hier
wettbewerbsfähige Bedingungen zu
schaffen und die Entscheidung wird jetzt
dann auch bald fallen und ich hoffe sehr
es wird eine Entscheidung für den
deutschen Standort werden aber wir
kämpfen den Boden zurück und das ist
genau die Haltung mit der wir herangehen
müssen